well i had a whole show planned but i
got to throw that out because i want to
vent about this uh oscar thing that
occurred i was watching the oscars last
night but i did go to sleep before the
big chris rock moment and uh yeah you
didn't know a moment was coming
so chris rock's a comedian he gets up
and if you're at the oscars and you know
there are comedians there and you're
sitting there you know there's going to
be a certain amount of
comedy about the audience they're gentle
jokes they're not
brutal
and he said wow that's a great gi jane
look it was i can't wait for g.i jane
too it's something g.i jane two there
you go and if you notice on the
broadcast will smith is defining he's
laughing because it's a
it's not even funny it was just he was
acknowledging jada pinkett smith in a
very lighthearted way
if you watch the the tape closely as i
have like the cebruta film
you will
notice that jada is not happy and he
sees the look on his wife's face and he
open hand smacks him right in the mouth
on tv now the first thing i said to
myself is what the [ __ ] is going on is
this a bed because where's security this
is a live television event it shows
where we are as human beings like you
can't even say something in a room
without a war breaking up here's nikki
glazer she's actually on the phone nikki
hi hi howard what do you make of it
nikki why is he allowed to sit there
after something like that that's what i
was kind of shocked by was how they kept
cutting back and he was still there and
everything was fine and then he wins and
everyone's a little hesitant at first
and kind of shocked and then by the end
of it everyone's
cheering and on his side but um anyone
who heckles during a comedian's
performance gets kicked out normally you
know as a comedian if you think about it
it's not even a knock it's it's kind of
a compliment i know for a fact it was
not a dig against her having alopecia
she
he definitely did not know that he never
would have made that joke had he known
it was
a medical condition that she had but it
would have been fine if he would have
just interrupted and said what he said
afterwards when he got you know muted
i don't know the whole thing was just
really depressing well it is bizarre
because this guy
has been
lobbying to win the academy award
forever
and the night he's going to win what
does he do he ruins the moment yeah he
was shook up there like he was so
ashamed so you can tell that's not
someone who's like excited that he just
won he ruined his own moment i was
thinking about the government went after
cbs television when janet jackson's
nipple made it on live tv
and yet will stand by and watch a guy
get assaulted with no repercussions i
like that they go well chris rock didn't
press any charges why does chris rock
have to press charges everyone saw uh an
assault take place everyone in the room
with their own eyes and then if you
would have tuned in 20 minutes later you
would have never known that happened let
me tell you something if jason momoa was
up there who's the size of a house or
the rock yes or the rock
will smith would have sat there like
that would have been the end he'd have
comforted his wife which is what he's
done
right sitting in that chair
well nikki thanks for calling and i
wanted to know what a comedian felt and
you made some really great points